good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Wednesday it's hump day I know
you're quarantined but if you're not
quarantined alone don't forget to do the
ceremonial humping of things on hump day
I don't know I think hump day is
canceled at this time I think at this
Junction and time hump day is canceled
hate to see it yeah I mean also April
Fool's is a little canceled
it's definitely canceled because oh but
I'm Jackee actually said the smartest
most poignant thing yesterday she's like
if anyone makes like a coronavirus prank
like I've grown a virus like I just
can't wait to see all the tone-deaf
people who think that those jokes are
funny
yeah and we're just gonna have an
immediate cancellation for that yeah and
you know I'm really against canceled
culture but I think I'll have to make a
special exception in in this case
actually it's a corona virus is the
pinnacle of canceled culture because
everything is canceled yeah and so I
feel like when this is all over like
canceling we'll have a new definition
right like postponed oh speaking of
canceling can I just make a statement
from a moment if I may may I sure I mean
um we were supposed to be in Vegas this
weekend which is really hitting and
cutting deep like I'm really upset about
it it's also Ben's birthday whatever and
we had gotten Kelly Clarkson tickets for
this weekend because what else you gonna
do in Vegas if it's not see Kelly
Clarkson I mean we were going to Vegas
for Kelly Clarkson and American Country
Music Awards and then they all started
for Kelly I'm literally gonna go to
Kelly Clarkson alone if you know one
wanted to come with me this was all for
Kelly we were going to the ACMs because
of Kelly that's true we bought like
seven of the most prestigious seats even
we were only a group of six we just
thought we might need an extra one like
we spared no expense and I got an email
that the thing was canceled a few weeks
ago and I don't know what reminded me
but yesterday I was like oh I should
check if I ever got the refund you know
like an [ __ ]
and I'm like searching my credit card
and I don't see the reef and I'm like oh
let me just reach out to customer
service literally I tried to live chat
with chicken master before I could even
respond they're like oh you're calling
back Kelly Clarkson yeah the owners of
the ticket organizers have decided not
to refund
yeah like when it gets rescheduled
you'll have a ticket are you freaking
kidding me you don't know my plan also
Vegas like if you're not gonna know what
like most people don't live in Vegas so
if you have tickets to a show in Vegas
it's because you were there that weekend
it was so disappointing so disappointing
and now that ever
weddings are gonna be moved to the late
summer and the fall like Kelly I don't
know that I could go on the weekend that
you think I'm gonna be able to go and I
know this isn't like Kelly's fault like
she probably has to know to heaven
there's no sway over the matter like I'm
sure it's the promoter and the venue etc
but that ain't right
no daddy right it's really upsetting one
because not only do we not get to see
Kelly Clarkson at a VIP table that we
bought yet with table service at a
concert it was so excited
Zappos theater also I'm out so much
money yeah very upset yeah all of us cuz
they're represented you and I know we're
not getting our money back ya know I'm
not sure it's her money I'm not sure if
everyone in the group paid me I have to
double-check my app venmo I'm pretty
sure that we did you know I think maybe
like literally you I mean because
anything for Kelly yeah I'll have to
double check my records but I'm just
really upset about that I'm really upset
that I'm not seeing Kelly Clarkson on
Friday and I said that there's not a
Kelly Clarkson ride on peloton and I
really understand that like these are
uncertain times and like certain events
or whatever like might not be able to
Vegas like we're small we're a small
business and we're putting on an event
and if we have to cancel it we are 100%
refunding everywhere of course it's like
you are like the Zappos Theatre in Las
Vegas
razzle dazzle and you can't give people
their money back yes so it was
frustrating for a show that hasn't even
like premiered yet yeah and I want to be
an understanding consumer and I
definitely even like with Delta like was
I annoyed that I couldn't get a refund
but I got a credit to Delta like all
right not ideal but you know what these
are uncertain times and I'm being an
understanding consumer but with this I
just thought it was really like low no
or just like have a plan in place they
tell us you will you basically have a
credit and when the show is rescheduled
you can pick any show and apply the
money towards that can I just get a
Ticketmaster refund yeah but just having
your money in limbo like 10 you're just
gonna tell me when I'm supposed to go to
Kelly Clarkson that's not how it works I
know how any of this works
something about that's not how any of
this works something about the show
being in Vegas makes this like extra
hutzpah dick you know like Vegas is show
like no one really well not no one but
most people if you buy a concert to it
if you go take it to a concert in Vegas
you most likely don't live in Vegas so
like just thinking that someone's gonna
make another trip because you decided to
be scheduled for January first like I
mean we are
well who knows where we'll be we're
gonna make multiple trips who knows
everything after Corona like I'm just
you're never gonna see me again by the
way I'm retiring after coronavirus like
I will not be working I will just be on
vacation farm chime in here they're
everywhere you know I was saying to some
of my friends via zoom yesterday like
don't be surprised when all this is over
like if you have a full calendar with
things for me like we're going on trips
we're going to dinners we're throwing
parties I was actually thinking last
night like the first day back like on
the weekend I think I'm gonna like host
a party like rent a room at a bar and
just invite like all my friends and
family my fear is that there's not gonna
be like a big first day back it's gonna
be like this slow roll and everyone's
gonna be like nervous and it's just
gonna be like weeks of like should we
shouldn't we restaurants operating at
50% until we get back to normal like
there's not going to be that big block
party that we're all if I can hoping no
that's like honestly I refuse to believe
that we live in that world I'm sorry
like the only thing getting me through
is the block party I know I know Bobby
I'm gonna host the block but I love a
block party I mean I will take anything
like I will literally take a dry party
like I will take anything I'm just dying
for like love I just like want to give
people hugs to like it's really it's
just all a part I don't know I just miss
like and I also do not miss handshakes I
think that those are just definitely a
thing of the past you get on if you see
me and we're in a business meeting but
these guys see signs what's good me and
Ben were talking about last night before
bed like what do you miss the most ooh
honestly I miss the family I miss being
able to be a family like oh that's nice
if you said something a little different
both actually said like and I meant like
I guess that's a good answer but we like
we don't have Shabab yeah we can't just
like go over to mom's like that's what I
miss them we said that what we miss the
most is just restaurants like I really
miss like going out for dinner going out
for logic there's so much like love and
camaraderie around a dinner table that's
not in your house that I really really
miss like the energy of being at a
fabulous restaurant and I haven't felt
that in so long you know what I do miss
because it's not that I miss restaurants
because honestly like learning how to
cook has been so great I eat pasta like
every night and I'm not gaining weight I
feel like an Italian yeah it's crazy
I've been cooking so much as well but
but I do miss like stuntin on these hoes
like now I put together a cute outfit to
like just go into obscurity where it's
like I miss
even like now when I wear something like
it doesn't matter what purse I'm wearing
no one's gonna see it I wear the
weirdest coats every single day because
I just want coats that cover the maximum
of my body yeah but like I miss just
like being with snatchler I miss being
with snatchler ya know there's just so
much that I miss and again it's really
putting everything into perspective I
think how much we as society took things
for granted before this and I will never
ever take the small things for granted
like I will never take you know a hug
for granted a birthday party for granted
a dinner for granted I will never
because I will always think back and I'm
really actually excited a year from now
to look at my time hop like of what
there's like the [ __ ] that I was doing
like literally just me in my apartment
pictures of the oh yeah that's me too
like I don't even know what I'm doing in
my apartment
oh I know what I'm doing being a big
[ __ ] idiot what you do try to wax my
armpits yeah oh my god it was it will go
down like when people say like what do
you regret most in life attempting to
wax my armpits it was so painful and
everything was going right like I got
the wax to be a great consistency I put
the wax on my armpits and that's where
things started to go wrong because it
was like oh my god I can't even describe
it it was like too thin so it was just
like basically eventually just peeling
off little bits it was so painful and it
was like mentally painful too because I
had to be mentally strong enough to just
keep ripping wood by the way it's very
hard to do self waxing like when you
bought the real like kit like that they
have it like salons like it was I mean
it was a good beads that you know yeah
it was a kid but it was still only like
$25 but it wasn't strips like you did
the real deal so to me that's brave and
then just like logistical your armpits
actually a very difficult spot to
recheck if you were doing your shoes
killing me it was so painful like and
then I I did one I just did like a
little patch it looks actually it'll
take a look it looked fine before
because I have such a light hair that
you can't even see it I just hate the
feeling of shaving your armpits it grows
back five seconds later and it just he's
like this prickle that's always there so
I was like I just want to wax my armpits
because that's what I normally do and oh
my god I will shave until the day I die
or I just won't do anything at all yeah
turkey I'm done like I literally I think
that was like the biggest crack of them
all Jackie don't definitely don't shave
your armpits because if you don't shave
them getting out of the cycle of shaving
is really hard because it grows back so
fast in different directions the next
time you get a whack
don't do it a million different ways yet
but then once I get that first wax back
I'll be fine
yep let it go out who cares you're
married I know I just like I I was just
trying to like have like yellow hair I
was trying to keep up some sense of
normalcy and it was so so painful and
just mentally exhausting I literally
finished I went I ate two sandwiches and
then I and then I fell asleep for two
hours like that was much like it took
out of me mental and physical well here
like you know I try to look look at
things you know with a positive lens so
now you have an answer when someone asks
you like what's your life's biggest
regret I have an answer and I've like
loved that I have an answer it's like
that whole cop car thing I spoke about
on the lady getting podcasts now you
have an answer I already had an answer
was that teen where I went on in high
school which was a bigger regret because
it was like I only stayed for two weeks
but my whole summer revolved around it
so it was basically 2 months worth of
regret um and that it was definitely
worse than not waxing my armpits because
I think my life would have been like
super different you're just not a teen
tour girl no I'm not a teen tour and I
don't know like what made you think that
you were it's just whatever like
everyone was a team yes and so why not
me actually never one feeling why not me
why not me I'll tell you why because
because you don't think because I'm me
so I'm a terrible traveler I get so
homesick like no and you know what and
now but like when I was like 14 I didn't
have like the sense of self to be like
this is not for me
you know now it's like I Know Who I am
and I know who I'm not not if I don't
want to do something I'm not [ __ ]
doing it but when you're 14 you have to
like say yes to every case we like a 14
year old who's like this 9 day this is
just not my speed yeah also something
excited but it's just not for me
something exciting that's happening
today from you that you didn't really
respond to my text message but I plan on
pursuing full legal action is you are
being taken for granted Jackie someone
is someone is a brand out there is
taking a picture of Jackie in her
tie-dye sweat suit from brown-eyed girl
and shopping it using it as an ad as if
that sweat suit is from their company
and they're using a picture of Jackie
and we fully intend to pursue this legal
action class action loss I saw that you
want me to pursue a lawsuit but here's
the team but if you don't email a lawyer
like I'm literally like oh my god like
emailing a lawyer will cost me money
this fake broke-ass website has zero
money I will just spend money
it'll just delete their Instagram
I will never hear I'll never get a fan
damages I'm not auditioning I think
money off of your photo and your
likeness I don't think they're making
any money and obviously you know who has
a real lawsuit on her brown eyes brown
eyed girl no I have the bigger lawsuit
because they're using my image without
my consent
but like an image that I own but I
wouldn't ever see a penny and I would
only be spending money on contact well
you know what I feel very strongly about
it and we're gonna we're gonna do it
okay if you want to take that on by all
means should we dive right in and we had
a great movie of the day yesterday that
I can't wait to recap I also have two
things that I need to say just to get
off my chest one
I don't laser which is what so many
people tell me to do because I tried it
my hair is too light and the laser does
not pick up the hair and it is a moot
point I lives with my armpits and now I
only shave my armpits about once a year
and it's fabulous I was like what I
tried laser twice and they had to get
the laser so high to even trying like my
hair is like so blonde you can't even
the laser couldn't see it to a
correction for me Esther days episode
about Isetta Mophie in' you can have a
said emoji and that's what's in tylenol
and it is in my doll and so I suffered
through my cramps for absolutely no
reason
it is ibuprofen that you cannot have and
I was very much confused and I apologize
for anyone who stayed away from my
ceremony yesterday and suffered any
undue pain well thank you Jackie for
issuing that correction because we are
nothing if not diligent here at the
morning toast and you know what
sometimes even professionals we make
mistakes you know we look perfect but
we're not no I'm but we really do look
perfect you like my new shirt I do it's
very uh toasted it's very spring merch
vibe yes we're still waiting on a drop
date so just stay tuned but we just want
you guys to get excited about the stuff
get a little taste yes should we die we
should dive in I just want to say like
one more thing um that I'm pretty sure
that this spring drop will be available
for pre-order so you guys can get like
whatever limited stock yeah that's part
of like what we're trying to figure out
but I think it's gonna be pretty order
for y'all we are also going to be doing
veer toasters today which is our advice
segment so if you or want to get in on
the fun email us to your toasters at
gmail.com we always keep it anonymous
you can write in about anything from
wedding stuff to quarantine stuff
anything we will answer so just let us
know let us know I really am so tripped
up today like to address the elephant in
the room
no no everyone wants it so what's going
on what else okay well what's going on
nothing what's going on is that each is
time yeah
each is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite of your morning toast
and they mean it is time but not to step
on anyone's toes or anything what do you
mean are wearing Gucci loafers it's true
I am there they're gutting so I wouldn't
want to get them yucky since they are
gucky but I would be remiss to
devastated maybe even Harper that's
suicide no could you imagine a world no
maginot world like that if I didn't let
you know that today's episode is brought
to you by OkCupid have you ever been on
a date where you just had nothing in
common with the person yeah on this a
date with this guy Ben he was such a
loser
yeah I mean pretty require very much
very much so a lot of people don't know
this but OkCupid has really changed the
dating game by asking you tons of
questions about yourself and what type
of person you're looking for the more
questions you answer the better they are
finding you matches you have something
in common with so some of the great
questions on OkCupid that really get to
the heart of people or and get down to
the heart of the matter of knowledge of
it so it's such a good song are you a
morning person no no he'll [ __ ] now
even though we do a morning show do you
make new year's resolutions no I think
those are for weak people I'm making New
Year's resolutions and by the way this
year I'm [ __ ] hitting them out of the
park I learned how to cook I now set a
goal on Goodreads to read 50 books this
year I've ready ready 17 oh yeah you'll
reach up yeah could you date someone
that couldn't be bothered to vote what's
a bigger deal sharing your bed or your
history in bed Wow bed obviously yes
anyways OkCupid asks the pertinent to
the situation cord cord cutters
questions anyways OkCupid works its most
mentioned dating app in the New York
Times wedding section which i think is a
huge vote of approval so stop the
mindless time on dating apps and go to
the app where you choose what matters
OkCupid is free get OkCupid for free
okay human
I don't even have to give you one of
those super long URLs with the code so
download OkCupid today and go on a great
date this week well not this download
okay keep it today and just start
chatting it's actually a great time to
lay the foundation with someone totally
are you done um and then tell us about
this person that you've laid a
foundation with hopefully you guys get
married and I will be there officiating
and I will sing yes I will sing I just
have to say that wasn't your finest work
but what is one to say like oh it looks
okay keep it like that coffee you know
but it's harder than it looks
yeah it is and also like I've done that
okay keep it wide like many times so I
basically know about her also another
symptom of me doing my arm hits last
night is that I like well I didn't put
on deodorant today cuz I didn't to get
like harsh chemicals into these like
open gladly yeah um so I'm sweating
okay that's exciting yeah okay ready for
our first story are you ready
that's an interesting question am I
ready yeah sure okay because Larry David
has some choice words for idiots
ignoring California's current abayas
lockdown oh my god this video was so
funny so funny Larry David is urging all
the idiots in California ignoring the
state's stay-at-home orders to take
advantage of a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to sit at home and watch TV
it is true this really is a once in a
lifetime opportunity yeah it would by
the way the video was so well done and
we've been saying a lot on this show
like celebrities are just giving us the
opposite of what we need right now like
in terms of content in terms of them
being so thirsty and this is just
exactly what we needed
totally he goes you're hurting old
people like me well not me I have
nothing to do with you I'll never see
it's just so [ __ ] true it's so Larry
yeah he notes that the state Public
Health order aimed at curbing the spread
of coronaviruses presented a golden
opportunity to lounge on the couch and
watch some tube he said I mean I don't
know how you're passing that up well
maybe because you're not that bright ya
know it was so funny he also said that
um if you know it you know anything
about me you know nothing good happens
when you leave the house it's true it
was a really well done PSA loves you you
know the iPhone quality loved to see
where you know where he lives it looks
like a hotel it looks like a nursing
home
yeah to put it nicely yes it looked like
a nursing home but speaking of the are
movie of the night last night was so
sudden
I watched she was a key I'd never seen
it before I got I watch you with bed and
he loved it oh wow I'm so excited to
compare notes yeah was she devil with
Roseanne Barr and Meryl Streep it was
excellent but yes back to this PSA
living for you know this celebrity X
politics like PSA usually I hate when
celebrities and politics like get
involved with one another but yes
fabulous no and and like in literally
this current Junction in time I know
everyone feels like all the time it's
impossible to avoid but we find a way to
avoid it but like actually right now you
can it's impossible to avoid especially
when like Governor Cuomo's the only man
we're seeing for the next few months
oh my god the tick talks about Governor
Cuomo are so funny because it's like
people in New York especially if you
live alone in your apartment like it's
the only man you've been seeing for the
last few weeks as Governor Cuomo's and
people are doing such funny take talks
of like pictures of Cuomo and the song
playing in the background like what's
wrong with me why do I feel like this
I'm loving the creativity that's coming
through a tick-tock from the youths when
they're left to their own devices you
know in quarantine nothing to do I'm
really feeling like this is a really
great moment to be a talker which I am
follow me at girls no job yeah follow me
at Jackie oh I totally agree and I mean
we've been and on the weather's cuomo
yesterday so I feel like we can table it
for for a minute but that's why
yesterday what yes yeah because Chris is
you know recovering after this though I
definitely want like a watch Robin's
live episode with brothers Cuomo like
something I can in depth and every way
you to something maybe haven't come on
the toes like now that weird like White
House official you know we are an
essential business it's good enough for
the White House its governor good enough
for the governor's house yeah I'm just
trying to be like realistic and maybe
like watch terms I've maybe Andy's
friends with Chris or something I think
after this like it's very realistic to
think of the brothers Cuomo yeah I mean
the White House called and we picked up
so who's next kim kardashian would love
to you she's actually doing a lot of
remote interviews like from her home she
was on the view she was on Jimmy Fallon
oh yeah I mean these uh like late night
hosts and networks are just like needing
people on their show so they're
literally like calling up everyone yeah
who they have like somewhat of a
personal relationship with because what
like what the hell else is there to do
also Bravo they've been doing a really
good job like
playing like seasons they're having like
marathons and today there's a real
housewives of orange county season one
marathon and it's just awful like I
think the fact that that show spawned an
entire franchise is shocking because
it's literally a piece of [ __ ] like it's
so grainy and blurry you couldn't see
anything and the story lines are so
stupid like Slade Smiley and Jo Jo yeah
and she like loses go gardening's she
has to wear a french maid outfit like
it's just so dumb oh and by the way
something happened actually I was
watching when I was doing my hair and
there's a scene in the first season of
real houses of Orange County where Slade
smileys parents are in town they're
staying at Joe's all together and they
need to go furniture shopping for the
house there's like a room that needs
furniture and Slade's like well I'm a
black card member so they actually
closed down the store after hours and
let us come in and shop you know
privately which first of all I'm not
entirely sure if that's a benefit of
having a black card I have to ask to the
points guy because he actually has wine
it's not it's definitely not was it
because have you ever got into a store
and they were like sorry we're closed
right now there's a black card member in
here no it was like after hours so like
when yeah okay for sure and then also
why it doesn't oh and all the Jews late
Smiley's deadbeat dad and he can't pay
his child support he's four so I I'm not
entirely sure again because I don't have
one but I'm almost 100% sure that
American Express doesn't give black
cards to poor people but that's just a
thought because like I'm just not sure
but that's the way I think that like the
whole system works I think that's how it
works as well and again I could be wrong
but I just think are you ready for our
next story because I feel like you
haven't a lot of more thoughts yeah cuz
Camila Cabello and Shawn Mendes did
their daily paparazzi walk and some some
angel out there filmed the walk instead
of just taking pictures a bit back at
grid thank you for filming it and they
just are walking so impossibly slowly
maybe they're not feeling well or maybe
they're just the biggest thirst monsters
alive who are like walking in slow-mo to
get the actual perfect photo this isn't
the first time this week well first of
all I just want to talk about
celebrities in the paparazzi and like
that's still going on in general like
what is paparazzi or not social
distancing paparazzi or not in the
central business no definitely not also
if you need the what if you don't know
what we're referencing I posted the
video on our Instagram so head over to
the morning toast Instagram watch it so
you understand what we're talking about
right and so
they're doing this like walk every
morning where they're getting packed and
by the way you've seen the paparazzi
pictures before this video like of the
last week and I'm getting coffee I did
see one last week where they are they
have paparazzi photos like of them
walking with their morning coffee mugs
and then another photo we're like
walking home and the mugs are completely
empty and like they're not stained or
anything it was like a fake mug oh my
god like a fake copy so like these walks
are so [ __ ] fake and it's like like
maybe I can understand how these things
are happening in the world like when
it's not current of time yeah but in
these current of times are you [ __ ]
kidding me no like honestly I've gone so
back and forth with Camila and Shaun
between like thinking that they're so
fake thinking that they're kind of real
but just thirst and then like thinking
that they're cringy and I don't know
where I landed in recent months but this
whole saga has totally changed the way I
think about them like I'm back to
thinking that they're fake asks like
they're not even quarantined together
like they're quarantined on the same
block and they get together for their
pictures yeah I feel like I saw them at
a restaurant once I don't know if I
mentioned this on toast I saw them in a
restaurant when I was in LA and they
were so on top of each other and there
was like no paparazzi no one was looking
at them as a small restaurant even
though it was like it's a very paparazzi
centric restaurant so maybe it was a
thirsty move but like they were just
like so obsessed with each other I was
like you can't do that with someone that
you're not so in love with so I believed
it and I also believe that any couple
that is quarantining together like
Israel as hell you know they could have
been like oh I'm quarantining with like
over here and you're over there um so I
think that they're a real couple but
they're also real thirsty and normally I
respect the thirst but just like right
now ya know especially if you're gonna
be 13 you're not even drinking anything
normally I definitely respect the thirst
but when Shawn Mendes went to the Met
Gala with Haley Bieber and then did that
Rolling Stone article like all about his
sexuality and how like he'll never be in
a relationship again we're like just to
make people prove things like it really
seemed like a genuine article and he
doesn't seem like a thirst monster to me
but literally I've never seen a more
thirsty like move in my life than taking
a walk and by the way you can get
paparazzi Don a normal speed walk why
the [ __ ] were they walking so slow like
they weren't jogging they were just
walking so on a regular normal paced
walk paparazzi can get a great picture
so what's the problem no idea and like
if they're gonna go through all the
trouble of like walking slow setting it
up why don't you put on some makeup or
like a nice shirt not like your pajamas
you know it's like we're going to all
the effort
and I guess he just really wanted to
look stage because who would leave their
house like that knowing that there was
paparazzi but it's just it's really
making me hate them again yeah and I can
respect thirst if I understand the end
game but I just don't see the point like
they're both big stars whatever you know
they have good careers what is the point
of stepping out every single day yeah
with the potential of something like
this happening because everyone's been
seeing their morning walk photos
thinking they're so cute in love and now
that we have this video like we're only
talking about that so there's so much
risk and I don't understand the reward
me neither
I feel like they're just jealous of all
the like stepping out attention that Ben
Affleck and Ana de Armas are getting in
a very natural way because they're like
constantly stepping out to walk the dog
or go to the grocery store looking
snatch getting packed and they're just
like trying to compete they're nothing
in the story that must be so fun for
them to like be in a new relationship
when it's still like it's you know the
rollercoaster of emotions in a
relationship is very um specific and
when you're in like that first stage I
don't you just say yeah yeah but it's
it's different it's like the honeymoon
stage but it's like you were just like
delivery obsessed with a person and all
you want to do is like spend time with
everyone you're not with them you're
texting them everything yeah and the
honeymoon stage doesn't apply to newly
married couples I need that's because
it's people that trust man each other of
course and by the way of course it
doesn't apply to married people like um
no but it's like a honeymoon yeah marry
no but it's literally like the second
month of dating I feel like like you
just got to know the person you decided
you really like them and like literally
everything they do like makes you
excited imagine everything makes you
laugh Oh imagine me in quarantine with
the person that you're like so
infatuated obsessive and and all you
want to do is stay home with them you
know and what I'm saying it's like when
you're normally in that stage like you
don't live with the person so you have
to go to work and it's like I'm gonna
text and like you FaceTime and like
there's all this but now you're just in
that honeymoon phase with someone you
literally can't leave your house like
all you can do is like talk and have sex
like that's so fun I'm so happy for them
yeah I'm happy for them too yeah know
that I am truly okay our next story is
actually a story that I was supposed to
do as the story yesterday and I just
completely forgot and we only did four
stories yesterday I don't know if anyone
picked up on the way you're wearing like
a totally white ensemble I mean before
Labor Day I am you know I'm just like
feeling I mean I know there's like no
trends right now or anything but I'm
just like feeling like a little like
winter spring white yeah by the way
those are your authors right I
course I feel like Rafi should be the
official shoe of quarantine no I agree
because one like you can wear them
around the house because they're so
comfortable and two like if you need to
like go for a walk or go to the grocery
store only to get the essentials and
you're wearing gloves and eye mask like
you can wear your off these two yeah and
I like that you can throw brought these
in the washing machine because if you're
gonna shoes around your house like they
should be clean so you're not dragging
around like bacteria and germs it's true
um so Rafi's they sponsored the show for
a while everyone loves them Jackie
literally wears them every single day
they make stylish sustainable shoes and
bags made for life on the go they're
carefully crafted with eco-friendly
materials like repurposed plastic water
bottles and marine plastic their shoes
are incredibly comfortable with zero
break-in period - they're seamlessly
knit design with so many chic styles to
choose from brought these shoes are the
perfect parent for any adventure
they're the best-selling shoe it's
called the point in black and they have
over 3,000 nearly perfect reviews online
they come in an ever-changing array of
colors prints and patterns they are
available in a range of styles they
launch new colors and patterns every few
weeks and they sell out constantly
Jackie's wearing just the plain white
ones and I think that slip-ons
yeah that's just a the can ones too and
like if you see me this spring I'll be
wearing my Rafi and I'm actually really
like more of the time hesitant to wear
white shoes but the fact that you can
throw these in the washing machine like
whatever they're seamlessly knit with
thread made from plastic water bottles
so they're ultra comfortable as soon as
you slip them on there's no break-in
period they have kept 50 million
single-use plastic bottles out of
landfills and have transformed them into
their signature thread which is them
then knit into the beautiful sustainable
product under another major bonus is
that they are fully machine washable
every time you need a refresh you can
simply toss them in the washing machine
keeping it clean just got a whole lot
easier so you want to check out the
amazing shoes and bags available right
now go to Rafi's dot-com slash toast
that's Roth acecomm are oth YS dot com
slash toast
comfort style and sustainability meet to
create your new favorites head to Rafi's
dot-com slash toast today Thank You
Robbie's firm sponsoring love it ok
next story that was supposed to be
yesterday's story so it's old news but
whatever Kevin Hart Kelly Ripa and more
stars are embracing their gray hair
during social distancing I actually
found this story really funny so
obviously you know just like I can't get
an armpit wax a lot of celebrities can't
get their hair colored and we're seeing
some celebrities and they are going
great I love this so Kevin Hart
revealed his gray hair in an Instagram
video series called confessions from the
heart admitting that he is a frequent
Dyer today the Sarah Silverman also
showed off her OnPoint quote gray hair
Heather Locklear Kelly Ripa Kyle
Richards but she also was giving herself
a root touch-up she says that she does
it herself quite often okay Tamera Mowry
it's right here exact chair it's also
blonde people like you I just yeah
everyone who's blonde is naturally
blonde but I was looking at Sarah
Foster's Instagram story this morning
she's like throwback to last week when I
was a natural blonde like I just I just
assumed blonde people are blonde cuz
I've never known a Sara Foster who
doesn't have blonde hair no it's also
because both of us and our whole family
none of us color our hair we've never
gotten highlights we've never changed
the color of our hair um so this is this
is like one maintenance like beauty
maintenance thing that we don't think
about at all no and I don't like
understand because I've actually one
time I really did want I like to have my
hair black but it wasn't allowed so yeah
I moved on real quick so it didn't even
occur to me I mean for people who have
gray hair but there's a difference
between like people who aren't getting
their hair colored like blonde yeah and
people who have gray hair growing in
that they usually touch-up yeah I just
think it's so crazy like who is a
natural blonde if like it's the
celebrities like I feel like Kate Hudson
is not she's actually not because
remember when she shaved her head it was
like brown yeah so like who the [ __ ] is
natural blonde I don't know like if not
these like even people who are natural
blonde they get their color touched up
they get highlights they make it a
little grassy ER or what erm in even
like all the Real Housewives of Orange
County I feel like none of them are
really natural blonde no I feel like
when you reach a certain age like you
just choose whatever hair color we drew
her go blonde no I wouldn't ever go I
don't think I'll ever get my hair I just
mean hypothetically like not obviously
because you have great hair color like
you wouldn't but like would you go
blonde that seems like too big of a
change
I can't imagine like just changing your
whole like because we this isn't
something we've ever thought about like
I can't imagine that's like just
changing your whole self yeah I'm like
the Kardashians go back and forth and
left and right yeah isn't like I just
can't imagine it I was recognized myself
there's so many people who I know who
like we're blonde for so long and then
went back to their natural brown and
it's so much
more beautiful like Addison Rae who I'm
like obsessed with she was blonde like
for her whole rise just tick tock fame
and she just went back to brown not that
I consider her a friend but you know
anyway and I think she looks so much
more beautiful I feel like that's such
like a an antiquated view like blondes
are like more beautiful even like um
Danielle Bernstein she was blonde for so
long when I met her and then she went
brown like I think just to try it out
and literally like she looks so much
more beautiful yeah I just think that
sometimes it's like the opposite like
remember when Lala was bombing and she
did super dark hair yeah I didn't like
the dye now she's in like a caramel in
between yeah and I'm true I guess it
just depends on the person it depends on
the person for sure
do you like when Kim does she was saying
Kim pushes her hair is so healthy now
and so now she can go and ruin it again
with making it blonde no I don't like
when they're blonde you know what also
they don't do blonde they do like gray
it's like so why yeah I'm them and when
it comes to Kim like when and when it
comes to her hair like I'm really in
love with like pre Kanye hair like when
she's to wear Blazers and just like a
big luscious way it was yeah and like
that was like their whole brand they all
had like the best hair like when you
would go to a hair salon you would
always take a picture of a Kardashian
like at an event for QuickTrim yeah so I
love like the big curls yeah I like
they're like natural vibe the most and
but I also love the Bob I don't not like
the Lord Farquaad at all but I like when
they're brunette like there-there was a
brunette cat except Chloe like she's
never really like what to me she's the
only one who shouldn't be brunette which
is just weird but oh I never even think
yes she's like totally but I'm like
she's been blonde for like five years
and I think it looks good I actually
like her hair styles yeah best yeah cuz
now when I look at pictures of her as a
brunette it's just it ain't it yeah and
her hairstyles are very much like hair
styles I would do like most of the looks
that Kim and Kylie wear like I would
never actually do could or would do my
hair like that but Chloe's always doing
like fun braids half-up half-down big
curls little curls like I actually think
Chloe has great hair I wonder who does
it they all have great hair though you
know I mean uh styles yeah that's true
the most relatable it's so interesting
because I'm here with my own like
struggles of how I'm going to manage
you're like yeah but then like Kendall
and Courtney like literally just a
flatiron their hair every day yeah well
I don't know think it's flatter I mean I
mean it's just straight hair yeah
but then also like which is nice to have
easy hair but then it's like less you
don't like growing up like I had to do
my hair all the time in high school it
was just like not cute and now I have
like the skills to do hair whereas like
people who grew up with like easy breezy
beautiful hair their hair looks the same
every single
you know that was me and age has
recently in the last two years changed
my hair but like in high school and
everything I'd like fabulous hair I
would just wake up with like nice beach
waves that like people would die for and
I took it for granted and then like
maybe two years ago I just tried to
waking up and my hair was like frizzy
and it was like breaking and it just
wasn't as good so I had to learn like
how do use a curling iron I really only
recently like figured out how to use a
curling iron when it's like you and
Olivia used to curl your hair every
single morning in the seventh grade yeah
which is like what school that we knew
how to do that but then like we spend so
many years of our life like ruining our
hair at a time when literally nobody
cared what we looked like so I like
wasted so much hair on say yeah you see
that now but like when you were in the
seventh grade it was literally like they
most important thing I know but like it
was but I just wish that we could come
up with hairstyles that weren't so
destructive but no one could have told
like I mean mom would literally tell us
to stop flattering her hair and you know
one could have stopped no and you guys
were insane like Olivia would take the
hottest [ __ ] curler she would have
wrapped her hair really tight and while
the Heron was still wrapped on there she
would spray it with so much hairspray
literally I was surprised that her
[ __ ] if curling iron didn't combust
like there was so much like flammable
[ __ ] happening and when you would spray
it it would make this like crunch it's
also a little wet Tuesday yeah Liberty
was frying her hair like I used to
watching aw but I never really did my
hair growing up except leaking I would
get like a haircut like a blowout and I
used to think I was like actually
Christy Turlington like I mean you were
and I was thank you it was really
confusing for everyone cuz they're like
is that Claudia from middle school or is
that Christy Turlington Oh awesome we
didn't say about head over heels
yesterday it's like that brunette model
the American one who was just like she
didn't have a thing she was just like
the girl she was like the bitchiest one
yeah she really looks like Bella Hadid
like the new face it's like that was the
model look of the 90s and its really
coming back it's like a pulled back neck
and a pull back face yeah I love it I
need to get pulled back yeah I need to
get my entire jaw line just right so
then also soon we'll start to see
celebrities like Botox slip and you'll
see that from I mean you already seen
that for me from my far head it's add
control when I FaceTime people it's just
like great it's going crazy yeah but I
think there are a lot of like
dermatologists who are definitely making
house calls in Calabasas so for sure
there are four like you know the target
level but like for influencers like me
it ain't happened oh yeah for low-level
jeffree star went and got Botox like a
week ago
yeah I I mean I I mean I'm all Somaly
how old am I who knows I don't want
don't say it and so I can go a few
minutes without Botox it would be good
for me so yeah yeah but like now that
I'm threw away my at-home waxing kit I
don't know what about do about my
eyebrows I've been plucking my eyebrows
with just soap ain't nobody know what
else I be doing plucking my mustache
like I've been getting my upper lip
waxed every month since the ninth grade
like it is just I and I probably didn't
need it in the ninth grade but like it's
just the idea of having hair on my upper
lip like actually makes me want to tie
that's why I was really hard for me to
watch she-devil because honestly before
yesterday I would have said just let it
grow mo notice no Roseann bars [ __ ]
and honestly when I look at other people
and they have hair on their upper lip
like it makes me disgusted like I just
think it's so nasty so the fact that I'm
now plucking my own upper left leg makes
Mona died does anyone know how beautiful
it is it's like one hair like you have
to go to the hospital if you do like 30
like it's so ghetto if you can't let it
get out of control and I've been on like
over the years like I've definitely let
myself go as sometimes I forget to shave
my legs I don't get a manicure but like
I never ever forget my upper lip because
I cannot be Rosanna I just won't be yeah
I'm sorry but her name Ruth Ruth
Patchett yeah but then when she had her
employment agency but was the name of it
like yeah I didn't understand you rose
yeah I did understand I was like it's
her name Rose Ange attorney into Rose
yeah because when she took the
stationery and was like Bob's assets uh
there was a Rossum yeah and so she made
that Rose was the logo all the women
were writing the kids and then it was
like Rose it wasn't exactly like genius
branding yeah okay I can't wait to talk
about it next story Kris and Kylie
Jenner came up with Kody to create hand
sanitizer for health care workers Oh
with their whip from the Kylie skin
facilities what's Cody the company that
that bought half of Kylie Kris and Kylie
Jenner about half yeah they bought like
not 50% it was either a little less or a
little more but she still owns about
half and for how much six hundred
million that's crazy
yeah which is by her valuation is over a
billion right Kris and Kylie Jenner have
joined forces forces with Beauty
conglomerate Cody which owns the
majority stake in Kylie cosmetics okay
so I guess majority are Dee and Kylie
skin to help health care workers amid
the coronavirus crisis as a number okay
there's like a lot of stats but anyways
they will be making hand sanitizer
you donate to emergency and health care
workers caring for patients on the
frontlines of the current a virus crisis
so they're not the first beauty or even
like company to convert their facilities
into hand sanitizer but it's Kylie so we
care and also you guys the stories out
there jeez there's nothing yeah but you
know this is really what dr. Deborah
Burke said to us if you haven't caught
our interview with White House Task
Force doctor dr. deborah birx please
check it out it's on our youtube channel
and she basically said like we said
we're like [ __ ] is wild like can you
make us feel better about something and
she basically said like she in her
entire life working in medical fields
working in politics she's never seen
such camaraderie between both sides the
aisles to Democrats and Republicans and
the private sector so she's like she
gets over 100 emails a day from people
who work at make companies like wanting
to help wanting to donate wanted to use
their facilities and this is like all
these fashion companies are now helping
make making masks Billy Joel just
announced that the gel foundation is
gonna give like 250 grand
to be strong so Bethany is like all over
it Bethany delivered her Instagram has
been so fabulous they delivered over a
million full-body hazmat suits to NYU
hospital Wow
yes she's just killing it like I feel
like if I ever had a lot of money and I
need wanted to help in a crisis like I
would just give the money to Bethany and
say like I don't even need to you think
I'll just do it but like right now her
problem if you follow her on Twitter
it's actually fascinating her problem
isn't money like she has the supplies
she has the money she has the
connections she just needs ways to
transport like millions of mass versity
trucks right in cars so she's always
like tweeting at brands and like rich
people being like hey can I borrow your
plane and a lot of times they respond
yeah I mean where are they going right
now right especially now
yeah like everyone's plane is probably
grounded this is why I just wish we were
like filming house in New York with
Bethenny like I would just love to know
what goes into like a world saving
pandemic charity yeah you know yeah I
would love to see it better like
someone's filming her and maybe they'll
do something with it you know I feel
like anytime celebrities doing something
like they just film it just in case yeah
yeah also when it comes to Kyle I just
want to say look when she donated a
million dollars everyone was like it's
not enough like I hope this is enough
for everyone to just shut the [ __ ] up
yeah totally
okay fifth and final story a little
stats news Americans are drinking a
crazy amount of alcohol during
coronavirus lockdown mathilde US sales
of alcoholic beverages have ribbon had
risen 55% in the
week ending March 21st according to
Nielsen data hard alcohols such as gin
tequila and premix cocktails is on the
top of the pour list and spirits have
seen highest increase with sales jumping
seventy-five percent compared to the
same period last year
wine and B are heavily flowing also wine
sales are up 66 percent and B ourselves
have risen 42 percent I believe it yeah
this is not anything new New York liquor
stores are considered an essential
business banner Cuomo and remain open
but even so national online sales were
up two hundred forty three percent far
outpacing store sales I mean I was just
talking about minibar like the best tab
I don't know if they have it in other
places besides in New York I'm sure that
they do it's such a fabulous app so and
I'm so glad that Cuomo did not close
down liquor stores because to be honest
like it's not really an essential
business but he's he's the governor of
the people like he is doing obviously
everything he can for the betterment of
New York but he's really I think he's
got long term plans because he's really
looking out for the people and the
people we're gonna pay him back we're
gonna vote him at office I have a
feeling yeah he's got some big big plans
and big big nipple rings no it's like
liquor stores are an essential business
just like restaurants are you gotta eat
you got haven't you got a drink yeah no
I would stay hydrated when this whole
thing was happening like an everyone was
freaking out and like the stores were
being cleared out I was obviously like
nervous like everyone was freaking out
the pandemic but I was just more nervous
about running out of food like that was
always my biggest fear but I feel like
I've now like I don't feel like we're
gonna run out of food like grocery
stores or open restaurants are doing
no-contact delivery caviar uber eat
seamless like they're all open those
apps so I feel good about that which was
my biggest concern yeah I agree
I feel like grocery stores they're
restocking they're taking necessary
safety precautions and I feel like out
for like a really crazy crisis like as a
country we're like we're doin okay ya
know for a really crazy crisis I think
it's being handled as well as it could
be handled and like everyone's doing
their part
everyone's chipping in from like the
people who are staying home quarantining
for the truck drivers the health care
workers the people who are delivering
food like and obviously there are
outliers that Larry David was talking
about but I think for the most part like
people are cooperating and I think it's
so nice some tell of humanity yeah okay
so on the news the other day that like
it was ten days two days ago so and now
would be eight days that Governor Cuomo
says were eight days away now from
peak deaths in New York City that's so
sad I know we just reached over a
thousand deaths in New York City from
Colonel virus so we have two more
segments off we're gonna recap our chest
movie of the day and then we'll dive
into dere toasters our twist movie of
the day was she-devil starring Roseanne
Barr and Meryl Streep a movie I hadn't
seen in so long
and when we saw we were really young
like I don't think I understood half of
like the the the plot because I just was
too young to understand it but I thought
there were so many things I remember
like that were iconic and I remember as
a kid and watching as an adult were just
as iconically when she blew up her house
like that except the green screen was oh
my god but act like would it not but I
looked it up the movie is from 1989 it's
literally in the title she-devil 1989 oh
my god it's so oh it's like old but it
holds up and like even I mean I'm
obsessed with Mary's Fisher's house and
I'm obsessed with her whole vibe and
it's like of course you know she was
hooking up with a married man and like
that is not cool but like she totally
like ruined her life and it wasn't her
fault it was Bob fault
so that was literally the note that I
ripped out in my phone part of the plot
that bothered me was that in trying to
take down Bob she like totally ruined
Mary Fisher's life who by the way it was
like a [ __ ] but didn't deserve to like
literally have her whole life taken down
and she didn't even try her goal wasn't
to ruin Mary Fisher's life it was to
ruin Bob's life but in doing so like she
accidentally took down Mary and that was
sad no Mosley I was glad Maryland back
on her feet but like she was like doing
the rinse cycle like it was making me
really sad it's a metaphor yeah and I
know that like technically she was wrong
and her and Bob were wrong but I thought
they were so beautiful together and like
loved them together and Roseanne like he
was a dick like but like she was so
pathetic like the way she like knew he
was having an affair and was like okay
with it she's like I'll be here waiting
for you when you get back like that's
somehow a wife she'd be and honestly
like I was eating a bowl of cereal while
watching the movie and I had to
literally stop because she was so
disgusting like with her mole on her
mustache and then like her shoving the
Eclair down her mouth like okay bye
Blair like it's probably like the most
iconic scene from the movie and like
when I think about the movie she-devil I
think about it Auklet Eclair oh when I
think about the movie she-devil I think
about her Meryl Streep's enormous
bathtub when Ruth is dropping the kids
off at a pool or a bath it's like a pool
that they made into a bathtub it's like
probably a natural water pool that house
was just incredible incredible and then
also there was a lot of inappropriate
things going on with the butler like and
Ruth's daughter like Emily she I don't
know
she looked like 15 I thought she was
younger and then she's like literally
dry-humping the kid but then also the
little kid is with the grandma drinking
champagne I can't know it was really
funny and by the way it reminded me a
lot of First Wives Club yes a woman like
starting a company for women and
she-devil came out like 10 years before
it's the original First Wives Club it is
like and I like I love the empowering
message and that's what I liked about
First Wives Club is that at the end like
they ended up making it like for good
for women and that's what I liked about
she-devil too but but here's my question
what was Roseanne's plan when she got on
the bus before Hoover got on with her
was gonna invest 50k into the bin he's
gonna figure it out herself but
obviously the moneybags got on the table
easier Oh like that little woman she's
so cute oh my god she's so cute yeah the
the time that she spent at the nursing
home was like my least favorite like I
just didn't need to see all the bedpans
for sure but then like she started to
pull her hair back and it was in ya know
but when she's at her desk in her
fabulous pink suit and she's wearing
like her hair in a bun and she has a
band-aid above her lip like that was the
best part of the movie for me because if
you know anything about me like I
absolutely despise moles like I used to
have like a feel my neck I got them all
but like I did sing moles are so
disgusting and I guess there's some
beautiful end cindy crawford but like
forever cindy crawford there's a 55
Roseanne's I just really hate moles
again you're like Dana I know Dana hates
moms I just want to chop it up and make
it a guacamole yeah it was a great movie
I thoroughly enjoyed Zach was like
watching it at first he's like this
movie is so depressing like he thought
it was gonna be like some sad tragedy
I'm like you know she gets her sweet
justice just wait till she starts her
employment like in case you were getting
any ideas
yeah wait also like him going to prison
was fabulous you know I do think she
took it like a little far like blowing
up the house sending him to prison like
just because he left her right but you
know what a scorned woman oh and also
it's like he was with Mary Fisher for
five minutes I was cheating on her left
right and so like he must have been
cheating on Roseanne their entire
relationship like where were you the
last 20 years
oh really I got the vibe that he was
very very faithful to Roseanne the whole
time but Mary Fisher was like something
special
no but like then he's cheating on her
with every secretary yeah it's like as
if you might unraveled I don't know I
just
make that clear enough yeah he was
obviously always cheating right but the
scene where she like bakes the gerbil
and the parent said he's taking my god
can you do anything right like that was
so sad yeah oh my god when the maid was
quitting and she's like up with this
[ __ ] I will not put - yeah yeah with
this [ __ ] I will uh put it was a
great movie and you know what it still
was good ten I'm Xena and like yeah time
you know um we didn't choose out right
our next moment we did okay fine but
then I have the next one because it came
up as related to she-devil and it's
available for rent on iTunes but it's
all for 399 but you can also buy it for
$4.99 and Zack and I are buying it we're
gonna watch it okay and I'm excited but
its beauty and beautician and the Beast
oh I saw that a little while ago with
that it's so [ __ ] a living treasure
so that'll be another day but tomorrow's
movie of the day okay but it's available
it's not on a streaming service do we
care where can we watch it you can buy
it for 399 on YouTube 399 Embudo or 12 a
99 on iTunes can you rent it on iTunes
that's my preferred that's my preferred
way to watch you say we should have done
this before sorry oh yeah you do I for
399 on iTunes okay okay so it's music
and lyrics and you know what it's so
good it's so worth it we're just being
so limited my head I've been searching
for so long I'm actually under
quarantine so it's like the kind of
movie that won't make you they won't
make you feel bad about your current
situation and you know I know people are
annoyed that we're not picking streaming
service movies anymore but honestly like
that's why toast movie of the day was
like getting really dry because we were
limited by Netflix and honestly Netflix
has no movies yeah no movies you know
what I watched yesterday that maybe
wouldn't be good for a chest move of the
day but just like a movie that I haven't
seen him for ever the pacifier I saw
that you had watched that Vin Diesel
Brittany Snow Lauren Graham like such a
good movie I used to watch that movie
all the time yeah and I had totally
forgotten like the whole plot yeah and
that's the Peter Panda dance it was
really good if you have time it son to
see Plus nice
so yes music I got a
realize Disney Plus more yes because you
know they have more than that meets the
eye Ben was going to Disney Plaza my
what the [ __ ] are you putting on and
they put them house fire ya know and I
have it I need to utilize Hannah Montana
forever
I mean of course okay let's do tear
toasters so our to your toaster segment
it's our advice segment if you ever want
to write in we always keep an anonymous
email us to your toasters at gmail.com
and our dear toaster segment is brought
to you by Felix gray there are a lot of
blue light glasses on the market but
they're not all created equal
many blue light glasses don't filter
enough blue light especially in the
range that matters
screens produce most blue light and at a
certain point in the spectrum which is
455 nanometers but most clear blue light
lenses only filter about two to three
percent in that range
Felix gray uses a proprietary filtering
technology to filter 15 times more blue
light in the same range your favorite
devices are a major source of blue light
phones tablets computers TV Kindles and
other devices and this can make those
devices can I can't even speak English
those devices are prone to give you eye
strain so bright screens in a dark room
watching TV you're working on a computer
in bed at night or really any excessive
amount of screen time in with the
quarantine everyone's screen time is up
and I feel like it's causing a lot of
people to have trouble sleeping at night
but if you wear Felix gray blue light
glasses during the day watching TV
reading a book on Kindle scrolling your
phone answering emails it can make a
huge difference and how you sleep
because they filter out 90% of the blue
light and most damaging range and elimin
eliminates 99% of glare through a
proprietary industry-leading lens only
available but Felix gray 9 and 10 Felix
our customers report significant symptom
relief Felix keyframes are handed our
hand finished from durable super
lightweight italian acetate with over
200,000 happy customers Felix gray isn't
just the right choice it is the only
chose choice you can order online try
them 30 days risk-free and if your
screens aren't easier on the eyes send
them back for a full refund
go to felix great glasses dot-com /
toast for the absolute best quality blue
light filtering glasses on the market
that's Felix gray fel IX g ra y glasses
dot-com / toast do what we did start
taking care of your eyes feel better
work smarter shipping and returns are
totally free at Felix gray at Felix
great glasses comm / toast okay no one
wants to pay for a movie so it's all
Erik's yeah so they just want to watch
trash on Netflix so the movie of the day
the hunter Matt yeah oh my god why like
I've been enjoying so much like off of
Netflix and everything these are
terrible
I know but they're like we they don't
want to pay for their rioting they're
riding all right so what is it then
we'll chose movie that day yeah no no
give them other one won't you just movie
the day no wait no I'm gonna go to
movies on Netflix I'm just gonna scroll
okay and Adam in a fine one okay and
I'll sing in the mean time okay way back
into love I'll do comedies okay oh my
god I'm so annoyed I really want to
watch music and lyrics hold on I'm just
gonna keep going what is it Dinner for
Schmucks oh you know what I've actually
been wanting to watch that okay that's
Dinner for Schmucks enjoy yep yeah what
you got it I wanna zoom you should just
assign the legend about to punish
everyone like I understand that people
don't wanna buy a movie but I really
understand doing you I watched music and
lyrics recently then yeah watched it
last summer um which is like recent for
me yes
so Dinner for Schmucks okay I've
actually seen that on Netflix and
thought it was an interesting title and
Ben said he's seen it and it's good so
Dinner for Schmucks it is do toasters
hello ladies I have a roommate who I've
lived with for the past three years my
boyfriend surprised me with a precious
man puppy in November my roommate is
trying to either make me get rid of him
or release her from the least who she
can move meaning I would need to move
too because I can't afford it alone
every time we talk about it she's a
total cont she hates dogs and I don't
have the money to move out especially
during all the corona mass what do I do
we're also not allowed to have dogs in
my apartment so if she tells on me I
have to remove him immediately my mom
can't take him and neither can my
boyfriend I love him so much I can't
give him away help oh my god this is the
absolute worst situation to be in and I
just want to say you berm it sounds like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] like people who don't
like dogs like I just I think are weird
yeah I mean it's obviously you have to
get rid of the roommate yeah but but can
you would sit down with the remain and
be like alright I'm willing to work with
you but it is corona time so can you
give me a few months yeah yeah yeah and
I couldn't expecting you to like take
care of all this today you know and by
the way like she should be so grateful
that you have a dog during current time
I could kill for a dog right now like
some to get a precious gem at home
shelters are almost out of dogs yeah so
one maker say thank you and then to
figure it out after these current times
but like she's a [ __ ] yeah and it sucks
because moving her out of your apartment
is so sad but a dog is like such it
enriches your life so much that if you
have to move into like a lesser
apartment or whatever find a different
roommate try and stay in your apartment
and find another roommate it's worth it
like literally having a dog is
everything to not give up the dog give
up the roommate she sounds like she
sucks anyway hey Claudia and Jackie
sorry
hey Jackie and Claudia she did say your
name first first and foremost thank you
for being such a bright light in my day
during this quarantine even though I'm
an East Coast toaster the change Junoon
is perfect for my new schedule as a
visual elementary school teacher as I
have a midday break and now can spend it
with you two I came to you needing some
time-sensitive advice i religiously got
a Brazilian wax every four weeks always
is scheduled on a Tuesday the day after
my period ends well that date would be
today but obviously my wax studio was
currently closed as you know the more
you wax the thinner the hair grows back
and I've been keeping up with this
routine for years my boyfriend says that
he doesn't mind but honestly I don't do
it for him it's just always been a
preference to buy cave and shave and
undo years of waxing no after watching
Jackie's story today about her at-home
waxing experience doing it myself is
completely out of the question
but now we're take talking months of
quarantine so like am I really willing
to just be unnatural until then any and
all advice is appreciated over here do
not undo it do you undo it I'm sure I'm
going through the same thing I'm coming
up on five years of straight waxing and
I'm not undoing the work that I've done
trim trim anything where it really
doesn't mind it and if it's just for you
trimming can get you really far you let
sit over the toilet with a little
compact mirror and a pair of cuticle
scissors you can get far yeah you got a
trim and then you just gotta it's this
is a once in a lifetime opportunity not
undo the years of waxing whatever you
did especially because like it's really
for yourself like why does your self
even care like no but by the way I'm
having here is my way for millions it's
like I do it for myself because when I'm
wearing a bathing suit or they serve a
but like I'm just laying in my house
like it's annoying but you just trim you
know I get it's one of these zones like
now I have to start shaving my armpits
it's not ideal but it's the situation
yeah but there are a lot of benefits to
getting rid of it like even if you're
just laying in the house like hygienic
ly like it's just who wants that with
your Burpee you'll miss a gently better
to have oh I don't believe that
I'm sure there's science but I haven't
found that to be sure which is why I
like the body even makes it in effort I
haven't found that to be chiral okay I'm
just saying like that might be science
but I generally don't think that's true
no I mean I think like literally the
entire country is struggling with this
certain of well women and I would I
would highly recommend to not undo like
the years of hard work remember that
first wax after you were shaving anyway
and you were scared and you got a wax
and was so [ __ ] painful you want to
go back you would do this to that girl
no no do it I'm okay third and final my
mother in law is the worst always has
been probably always will be my husband
and I are very private we really post
photos of our one-year-old son we
recently found out that we're expecting
baby number two when my husband told his
mom she immediately posted it on
Facebook with the ultrasound picture I
was only eight weeks and I've had a
history of miscarriage and he didn't
want to post about it until I felt
comfortable when I told her that she
told me that I can't control her and she
can post whatever she wants we've
already told her that we don't like
posting photos of our son and when this
happened I snapped an astronaut to post
any pictures of my son or about the
pregnancy unless the photo has something
to do with her like her with my son my
son with the toy she got him etc here we
are three months later and again she
post my most current ultrasound picture
in every picture of my son that we ever
text her now no matter how silly the
post now no matter how silly the don't
post request is she's outright ignoring
our wishes my husband called her and
asked why she would blatantly ignore her
which isn't she responds with she's just
gonna block us on facebook so she could
post whatever she wants I get at this
point telling someone not to post things
on Facebook is so dumb but she's
literally ignoring what we've asked
am I being dramatic resist off-the-wall
you are not being dramatic uh stop
sending her pictures yeah you're giving
her content stop sending her the content
and you know what maybe then she'll feel
like she's not being included or like
she's not being like updated on the the
status of her grandson or her future
grandson I'm like maybe that will get
her to stop doing it if in a few months
she's like you don't send me pictures
anymore you said cuz you post them on
yeah maybe that's how you show learning
I understand that you can't help but to
post you're so proud so I just want to
be in a position where you can't stop
yourself yeah and no you don't get any
picture saying you know what you can
repost anything that we post yep um but
no fresh pics for you that's so crazy
honestly whenever I do tear toasters I'm
like I'm so grateful for my in-laws like
they're just so totally normal I totally
I feel like when it comes to in-laws and
that's a great movie to Jane Fonda and
JLo monster-in-law you really see like
how bad people have it like that's crazy
that's so rude
it's so rude and then it's also just
like a weird relationship because you
know you're supposed to with any like
in-law situation it's usually like a
mother and a daughter-in-law
there's like you have to respect like
your elders and she's like your mom when
you have to talk to her like how you
would treat your mom at night even
though she's like a [ __ ] stranger and
she's being rude you know like every
time I read this stuff about tear
toasters I like to text my in-laws my
love you guys anything I'm bringing some
toilet paper
totally Wow I really have to pee this
has never happened to me I actually have
a grocery list on my phone and I'm
realizing I think I may be out of toilet
paper
oh [ __ ] I wonder if they still have the
last time I went to the grocery store I
didn't need but I saw and it was like
the worst generic like cardboard up your
could not be cheesy I made Charmin I'm
so you know we actually have a lot of
extra toilet paper here okay you could
take a yeah yeah okay is that it so I'm
you movie of the day is Dinner for
Schmucks it's Paul Rudd right it's on
Netflix
all right so enjoy and if you're feeling
like you want something else to watch
and you got three bucks to spare head
over to music and lyrics it's really
good okay also today we are recording
our newest episode of the redheads I'm
so excited I was putting together the
outline last night and I think it's
gonna be some really thought-provoking
conversation we're recording via zoom so
it's not gonna be like as per fatty but
we'll get to the heart of the matter you
still have time to read the book of you
start right now before the episode comes
out tomorrow because it will take you
like five hours flat if you just want to
well it doesn't rip a whole month to
listen to that so that's true but like
you know you just wanna be in on it with
the girlies
so definitely read this book it is so
easy fun and good if you haven't read a
book in a while like I think this will
just be like a great book to like bring
you back into the fold and the episode
will be out tomorrow so stay tuned for
that I'm really excited there's also new
episodes of Margaret Joseph's podcast a
maternity live this snatchler mood with
Lauren Elizabeth Wednesday's are big for
tienen so make sure you subscribe to all
the podcasts following toast news
network on instagram follow the updates
Olivia last week episode people were
like obsessed with she sat down with
Matt who's her trainer from the live
method who's also a new dad and people
were obsessed with it so also was doing
really cool things on Instagram if you
need a good at-home workout check out
their instagram at the liv method
because i'm sure you're all like me and
we've cracked and we're working out in
the home now oh also big news is that
one of our talents one of
clients host of the snatchler her name
is Margaux lingerie she's our sister
she launched a YouTube channel yesterday
she worked so hard on her first video to
get ready with me plus QA where she does
her makeup answers questions she had a
lot of questions about like being laid
off and she's just like you know telling
people where she's at she's a little sad
so she's um I actually was thinking when
I was watching her video like she
actually could be a huge youtuber
because she's young and pretty which is
like all you need to be and she has like
an interesting family with like a little
controversy which is so Olivia Jade like
I actually think Margot could fill the
gap that Olivia Jade left in the market
totally and she's just being like so
honest in herself and even though like
she's you know I'm Instagram and she has
the snatcher like where she talks about
other people like it's really this niche
like you've never seen her before and
I'm really I'm getting to know her and I
mean I think it's like watch her
throughout quarantine and then after
quarantine and see how she flourishes
once again yeah I think this could be
big for her like I think we'll be going
to VidCon 2021 you know totally I think
like soon people will be like oh that's
the snatcher sisters
I wish oh my god alright that's what we
got for you guys thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube but we are going live at
noon this weekend until further notice
as the quarantine is upon us so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found set Spotify iTunes stitcher Public
Radio I harbor they'll cast box all the
places whoever you listen to podcast
find us the morning shows
leave a five star view about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much we will see you
tomorrow for our final show of the week
we are not doing a show on Friday so
tomorrow's our last show of the week and
by the way our seats are switch because
it's April Fool's Oh does anyone was
curious we hope we gotcha